process of customer feedback am actually
looking at Rochford I've outlined here
basically really what the processes and
any changes that I've actually made and
the main change that I've actually
looked at was howling reporting and how
we were dealing with play minor
complaints that complaints of more of a
service nature and which wasn't really
been very clear about what we were
actually doing without because I think
there was a bit of confusion around the
formal complaint we log it and it goes
through a natural form of the process
and whether we look up with something
things up about a mr. bean or abounded
vehicle and how that steel windows and
whether they'll be actually and logged
anywhere which they actually are so on
the customer and feedback form and on
the customer feedback that is on our
internet for our customers to see on how
we deal with our complaints and you'll
see now there's a new in formal
complaint process which means that we
have an opportunity to actually if
someone finds our first call resolution
that we can actually resolve that call
first time they are all recorded within
the appropriate system so that we are
aware of them and that is actually free
to do any major will change that I've
actually made through this process and
I've outlined how we are reporting
internally that will go to our
leadership and team onto LGS lto
and it is reporting to executive on a
six month basis so I don't like this any
more questions of any questions I think
we do have a few questions with that we
done yeah thank you mmm there's two
areas john Gerard like to explore in
more detail because there wasn't a
detail there for me under 3.5
instinctive as requests to show specific
details and complex on future of course
the paragraph actually indicates that
that's not going to happen where did the
request come from as the first part of
that question and why was it considered
unnecessary to fulfill the request and
rustic coming from he was a question
that was asked previously for review and
it was felt that the the information
that is on the log and the actual detail
it wasn't necessary to put into the
report that goes into executive and it
doesn't go in there and it's
proportional statistics and performance
and the detail of who's made the
complaint and and the detail of what the
complaint is is for the officer to
actually investigate and looking to I
suppose the follow up on that one is
then okay is the responsibility of the
particular officer I don't know what
level that Officer is and I don't know
what process would be adopted in the
department concerned do you know and
obviously it would depend on the level
of the complaint because some of the
complaints we get it's a bit about a
service failure that will be the officer
who's responsible that could be the
manager that could be an assistant
director and it will get escalated as
appropriate if it's obviously a
major complaint it would be
investigating it will obviously be talk
through the portfolio holder because
they're not all not all complained of
severe complaints so depending on the
severity of that complaint will depend
on the level of the officer that will
deal with that all of the complaints are
seen by Assistant Directors all of them
the detail and now discussed by this
isn't directors within their teams as
well so they have before details for
them to be able to resolve them and to
know what the detail of the complaint is
and who's made that compound I'll leave
that their chairman because I know
counselor butcher is going to continue
with that in another in another thing
which I think it runs on from and if I
continue to ask all of the questions
that occurred to me it would be me and
nobody else asking questions but I did
flag to you chairman that times I wanted
to talk about the paragraph 3.6 and I'm
going to just start with a simple test
to me these are the informal stage
complaints can you tell me how many we
received in say a week month three
months I can't at the moment when that's
something that we know we do Lock them
onto the system and a service requests
on to the systems these things like
being this thing is really difficult but
I couldn't tell you I've got the
information to tell you how
that's something that a free run of a
system that goes into a back office
system and reports it most of these are
whether the large contracts so it's for
monitoring the contract it's probably a
person who manages that contract who
will have that information handle they
will be they will use that information
usually with the contractor for contract
management I understand that German I
would like to see this committees know
how many are received in appearing in
periods of time and I said a week it
could be a lump it could be over a
three-month period is actual reporting
period into maybe categories or maybe
even contracts because I believe that
they they are complaints they could be
looked on its feedback but of course
complaints our feedback our kind of
thing but if it's significant that we
might like to consider doing or hell we
ask further questions at exactly how
they're managing to ask to see some
examples maybe follow them through at
the moment I say that is something that
you know drifting to the bottom of the
tank with so the the rest of that
paragraph has been ultimate sentence
talks about these will be dogged so I
take it until now they haven't in love
previously yeah they may have been being
logged their own any call that we we get
for a service whether it's a complaint
or whether it's to answer for service
gets put onto our one of our systems as
appropriate
if it's for environmental services if
it's a housing then it will get put on
to the system and it is it would be
better for me to know and focus in on
exactly what information would like
because if you can understand there is a
huge vast amount other different
subjects within within our different
system that we have so that's why any
one time the officer within the service
or the manager for that contractor you
know specifically asked for information
and we can get that off but it's a bit
difficult to do it for every system for
every every area would take probably
quite not resource to actually do that
and this is specific areas you would
like information well unless that is
done Chairman I don't believe that the
council has a full view of the number of
complaints it actually receives about
its service and other mysterious
mountains we know about the serious
matters because their hand in a
particular way through through senior
officers are low but otherwise i'm far
from convinced that as an organization
we have a proper handle on it at the
president you know what I was committee
to make a finding that says we need more
information and I would say that it's a
discretion of you together with the
appropriate officer in charge of a
particular service or a particular
contract to choose you know which
countries are best reported on but as
the further questions share and it's
just appeared to me in passing in terms
of the more serious contains if you like
any informal ones these only own up the
only are all of them recorded regardless
of which type of opposite
to in other words people phone they
found customer services and I would
imagine that they arrange for things
that gave log does that mean that across
the whole organization every officer
knows what to do where the complaints
are loading nearly than the truck yes
they know the routes complaining has to
be larger listen yes thank you and it
excuse me you my notes I took at home I
lost because I can't be on today but
I've had a quick go through again I'm
just a bit confused on on paragraph 33
it says revenue revenues and benefits
looked into whether following the
completion of complaint the complainant
could be contacting for feedback however
due to staff resource but this will take
it is not feasible at this time that
worries me because it is only a phone
call and if you look further into the
customer guide there are number how it's
done informal we will acknowledge
receipt of your complaint stage 2 we
will always let you know stage 3 keep
you up to date as to the progress and
advise you of the outcome if you've been
advised of the outcome why have we not
got the time for the feedback and the
other Milan concern about this under
complaint it says negative experience
calls directly by council policy staff
for work occasions where the council
fails to deal with issues effectively
and or within a reasonable time scale we
haven't got on here what a reasonable
time scale is now my idea of recent
times going
about this might be looking two weeks I
don't like phrase recently trans guy I
would like to have it specified and yeah
it's it's um we didn't could be doing of
it that's sorry that was slightly
misleading i think that was i was asked
with her when I complained had actually
been with I've dealt with unresolved
whether we were customer services that
somebody would be able to go back and
say you know are you now satisfied are
you happy with the way it was dealt with
after we'd actually completed the
complaint to what would appear to be the
satisfaction because a complaint we
could have complained that we can
resolve within 24 hours and obviously we
always contact the person I mean when we
have to make sure that's completed and
resolved whether that's through a letter
through a phone call and that is
reported back to him the leadership
support team for them to be able to
complete it off this is where we was
being asked whether once it being
completed off whether we could go back
to that complaint so was that okay for
you was that process okay at the moment
we haven't got the resource to actually
go back once a complaint has been
completed off and resolved to go back
and say was that fine for you was that
place that's okay and yeah it just isn't
the result to do that so any all
complaints as they are not and at the
end of the quarter when we're going to
reporting it or whether if they've been
delayed because we have told somebody
that we will resolve it within five days
and that they always get a letter to
tell them when we're going to resolve it
if it's going to be a lengthy complaint
and I get a few of them and that come in
sometimes that around revenues and
benefits and they actually can take a
little bit resource to actually resolve
because we need to go back through
history but we've always go back to that
poem and tell them
give them a rough estimates to the time
when we're going to actually resolve it
so it's quite difficult to say we can
resolve we can resolve a complaint
within five days or ten days but we
would always write to them and tell them
the time scale or give them a idea of
the time scale if that's not feasible
then then a leadership support team will
go back and say to them unfortunately we
need to carry out further investigation
which does sometimes happen because of
the nature of the complex of some of the
complaints but we would always go back
and let them though and so this was
maybe a little bit confusing this was
around where it was completed I was
asked whether we could actually ask that
person whether you know they were then
satisfied with that when they're advised
of the outcome if it's difficult to go
back and have another step if you like
which I does concern me because I think
this is a new a quick phone call but if
that is not possible when they're being
advised of the outcome can they not then
be asked have you been satisfied with
how you've been dealt with yeah I mean
that could be that we've written to them
I mean that the corresponding really
later yeah whichever way however they
are notified of the outcome yeah in that
same scale rather than having another
step that same day yeah are you
satisfied with with this out yeah but
that is in the letters that are sent to
to the complainant and it does give them
a link the option because we sometimes
will exhaust all of the avenues that we
can and it will be limited to say that
if you know are they satisfied if
they're not satisfied then can go to the
Ombudsman and that is in standard in
in a letter yeah so that that is in a
letter to propose out to complainant get
down don't belong this gotta make a
suggestion instead of trying to follow
up every single one although the option
is there in the way we reply well why
don't we do a sample it's a possibility
you go back to certain percentage of
customers and say well you said is what
we got to do every month you can start
looking start but you know it's that you
know don't want to sort of over resource
/ resource this into EE checking if
somebody satisfying lingers quite often
and the officer has dealt with the
complainant in a very perfectly well way
and the complaint has been resolved and
the letter has come in history its be
resolved and we could follow up but the
you know it's what results we will get
from that the place they just thank you
you're receiving my letter because we
can't do some sampling and of that we
could get customer services to do a
couple of some things just to make sure
that the complaint has actually been
resolved and so we could do that myself
there's a lot of cottage chairman and
that is there ward members to
because often they come through me
anyway I have a number through me Jack
did you have a question yes if i buy
most of its more there's been captured
in what's been said but for me any any
system it's an incredible it shows its
performing right on it and i see that
the customer service is a painful an
extremely bored bar of this authority
and when you get a complaint and i
distinguish between there and comings or
referral because of something's broken
parole or whatever it's almost Pacific
combine that to me is a serious issue
and there should be recorded as you
quite rightly side it should be
investigated but it should be also fed
back to that person well I don't see and
I can't get on ice machine I'm another
one doing this wonderful system is that
what I don't see is we come back to more
less what to cleanse the Mesa less a mr.
MouseMan saying is that I don't see any
fitness of satisfaction or results I
don't see anything I can feed back and
as a member I'm aware of a number of
complaints obviously because my award is
for syphilis in complaint is that i
don't if i was to ring up i'm not saying
i'm going to get accessibility to those
complaints and sometimes while gathering
up these complaints they actually are
white to what it is i'm referring to but
i can't access them because of the
nature the component right there because
this department dealing with it that
Devon stadium design and I photos are
being [ __ ] up my glasses are not so a
bit more accountability in the resulting
system so even as a member I'm not
saying Joe public i'm talking about as a
member looking for the best of this
authority on a resonance that i should
be able to access that information and I
don't feel okay and then therefore to me
it's not credible I'm so similar then
yeah I mean it that's not a personal
thing you I'm not sure that we report
you know a report on the results in the
performance and how many complaints
we've had an assist that go off seems of
executive them we look at LT on LTS i'm
not sure what how we can make the
information available because if i may
be seven thought I come back on that the
point is that you said earlier on that
you feed it back through the assistant
directors they ever meeting again
director for party or elders and
Caribbean executive but there's a rest
of the members involved in this as well
but nothing seems and I'm not blinding
any particular remember this but there
nothing seems to go any further than it
and as a member i do Phyllis ecology
from it a Sarah feel I feel as though
it's all right some people knowing
what's going on as a member who's
working for the best of its authority a
fit as I should be exiting that as well
but I don't get that feedback but all
I'm asking for is a quarterly or
something before something that I can
actually get my teeth into an actual
exam then if I've got a question I can
answer the question thing rather than my
toe moment like this but that's really
when I'm getting something I think that
would be that would be helpful um i have
another thought i'd like to see the
solute evidence of trends of complaint
now the council's got financial
difficulties complained about the fact
that a service is no longer performing
door we've been reduced is in my mind
important but a totally different one
from someone complaining about a service
not being performed or someone being
moved or or whatever and I'd like to see
how in these difficult time should we
say if no complaints about non
availability of services I'm back going
up which would begin to be helpful
the report that goes into consecutive
dust does show some of that it's very
much as you say a statistical report
knob viously the detail is behind that
if it was requested of me you know he'll
show the details on the card show
detailed the complainant was but we do
look at trends and that is reported in
to that report if we do a possible to
circulate that two members as well and
no not suggesting that day to be your
decision we might beat up somebody to
see ya we can request is a committee
chair yes okay ya know my name is Jerry
I think you make a very relevant view I
mean we're not here to be anybody up or
see you lose a full I mean we're here to
make the best for the council and if
there is a lacking of resources or some
other issue and if we know about it we
can support that if we don't know it
just digs a bigger hole and there's a
deeper you know I which is fall down
into the hole and I think that's
relevant from a positive point of view
c-can you further gun okay factually
then gym I just reach a constructed
locking the girl no me sort of touched
on it House people I just need
confirmation Heather locking works
really again we've got Abba beer I'm not
sure comments and complaints of can be
separated days later I think Cass
Gibson's just mention a few complain
available if you say about a service not
being here then it would seem to come
under a common rather than complain so
I'm just wondering how the locking works
is is a comment and I an informal
complaint and a double to complain or
locked on the same system ordained so if
you come in and you say what up I've got
a complaint listening formal complaint
we go jazz and it goes on to a system is
that the sea same that he's given a
reference now then follow through on to
the leper to compare level 38 Antony's
on the same locking system and would
look the comment beyond the same system
as well be the more informal term or
around the service ones they get logged
on to the appropriate service back
office system that we use 04 we're
talking about band
vehicles or my smoked usance or
something that would go into the service
areas system for that report to be taken
off of there if it's not like it's a
form of the stage 2 then that goes on to
the more formal system because that
funds through you know a period of time
before usually that would be resolved
what we're trying to do is is when
somebody brings up we always use miss
beans but if somebody means up says miss
thin they want that down quickly we
raise a service request to the service
so that's picked up straight away and
that is resolved and then that's
completed off and that's that's doubly
the back office systems were able to
work the work flow through that that we
can send a request down to that service
area for them to do a straight away if
it comes to a stage two were that's held
or something has absolutely found that
it needs to be logged formally and so we
need to write that person is to be
escalated it make it escalated to an
assistant director rather than just the
service area then that goes on to the
the formula logging system which is
currently sits with the leadership
supporting so I just looked up how did
you know it needs to be escalated would
only be escalated if someone phones up
again or with canopy escalated by
manager correctly a low blow member of
staff will always be escalated by that a
personal panic just be if it means not
collective they phone up say mommy's not
being collected obviously quite often
normally they do come prep them
sometimes they might not do if they
don't come and collect you again how can
we yes without the track meet me
escalated geez that that would that
would generally and I can't speak 100
percenter that would get to this the
customer services if they came back and
said I you know I said my being hadn't
been collected as soon as it's being
collected that would get escalated
through to a form
okay because i'd say a absolute failure
of the service you know different
contracts have different ways of dealing
with complaints systems that we have to
be aware of that that we give the
contractor an opportunity to be able to
resolve a problem but they clearly
haven't then that is a failure and that
is a complaint that needs to be logged
formerly again that will then show up if
we've got a number of those then we can
look at those and say well we've had
eight ten within the last month is
clearly an issue that's happening here
that they're not resolving these these
problems clearly straight away so that
should flag up then that we've had an
uncle complaints about the same thing we
would see that through a normal review
fat cells are there any way I was
flaking that up or would that be reliant
upon the contractor telling us or would
it be a scientist and director or
manager but that would be down to when
we do in the reporting it would be
flared up relationship supporting will
sometimes flag them up and say we've had
a number of issues around miss bins or
planning or some some service bank they
can play will flag them up to the
appropriate service area if that happens
pretend to get them in spades that's
been an issue and it will come in and
it'd be quite quickly raised we can see
if there is an issue and or otherwise it
will come out of the reporting system
it's been over a period of time because
sometimes it be over period of time
might not be until a short period it
might be over a period of a few weeks or
months and I mean they're porting comes
out we can see that we may have been an
issue we've got a particular contract or
that particular service area so just as
summarized my understanding then if he's
the informal complain each service area
will do with it differently on a
different system is that correct penny
or not that well this what it would
happen is what the services that there
the level is here that could it was
generally be resolved straightaway
problem yeah but it doesn't
automatically create even to them no
because they have to be extracted they
will be extracted ring system did you
blow the questions even yeah I've got to
Jenna that's okay else to it relates to
1.1 I'll call region 1.1 it talks about
the review being carried out by
yourselves how did you I see conducting
her with what staff and go um as in
these via I mean start far involved in
or you know all of the processes and
it's not it's not the stuff process that
as as such as you may just have to be
aware of what the complaint is and
identify what what a complaint and they
have an understanding of what they need
to do with that so you know the people
that are looking i will get calls or
whatever we're involved in understanding
you know how they should deal with the
complaint basically
okay I don't think I went as far as the
chairman we thought it is going to go
that we're in our preaching so i'll
leave it to him this everybody wants to
follow up on that because i just wanted
to be the ice broker to make sure it was
right there with you Jim the other
question is is rather specific and it's
about what i call handoffs and you'll
probably recognize the term straightaway
it's where a call center receives a call
about an issue in a complaint is usually
involved but the call center can't deal
with themselves they don't have access
to the information or maybe don't have
the technical knowledge and the term is
though that complaint is then handed off
to someone else in the organization who
has the knowledge and other hand ups
actually dealt with does that become the
ownership of the person's handed off to
or does the call center retain ownership
and therefore go back to the customer
how is it dealt with what's the
procedure it's quite important because
if we lose sight of those very we're in
deep trouble mm-hmm and the kind of
thing we do with such survivor diverse
different areas different subjects
different service areas so some of some
of the areas that the customer services
will retain because some of the things
are they responsible for if it's a
complaint and it may be sent it down to
be logged to the leadership support team
as far as it it's they're not as I a
formal complaint in that way then they
are responsible for ensuring that that
is monitored and that the complaint is
is actually completed to the
satisfaction of the complainant and if
it's a more round of service complaint
where they can resolve it first
resolution then they take ownership for
about to ensure that that is resolved
fading at various emails and they will
take responsibility for
but they don't take responsibility for
everything because that as you say they
don't have the technical knowledge to
always do that so they didn't have to
refer them on to somebody else to deal
with but if they are obviously not quick
resolutions that they can deal with
themselves they are sent down to the
ship's 14 first men to love and then
that's passed on to the appropriate
officer for them to deal with thank you
don't thank you about to pick one up far
more than me but the first thing that
immediately comes to mind is what we've
all their righty and all the things
we've got going are we not centralized
in a compliant system I mean if we if a
complaint comes in and it put on a
computer and you pass that
responsibility to another Department why
is it being separated why is it not just
thing built with or that officer wasn't
there sensual and I bow to anybody with
pepper not easily but playing a central
feature about this this council where
you have one complaint system which logs
everything and it's not impossible
because I know working for other
agencies and those people regardless of
department or they like that officer in
the clouds they are responsible specific
point of contact whatever but it would
all be centralized by one program and
when you want to start getting your data
or if you put in whatever comes are
necessary and you draw that data and
there's no argument about vibes done in
and dealt with it and there's no them
and us it's all about us and then it's
no distinction or customer services are
to me is an importer is a person who
sits there takes it over the phone deals
with it we start happy to say they do
well and sits there and deal with it the
person whatever the consequences are
enter it into a system and then that
person deal will do that cut I we've got
so many different room when I take
contract are we not I mean I don't
and I open it up for someone to explain
it to me because I just don't know why
we got one system there's no question
I'm kind of different soap series have
different computer and IT systems I to
be honest the reason of one if there was
it would be wonderful there is no one
single system that does although further
services if anybody ever invent one my
life is that much easier on to item 8 in
any way we do have disparate systems
that do Pacific functions and they
written for that whether i'll be doing
that we love the Metro complaints on one
thing there are some complaints are not
in one place the other complaints such
as part of the process of where the
function is there is at the moment no
centralized way that we do that day so
maybe they cook there will be a cost
first unified and that's that is a good
answer but the question comes on further
from macy so we still let that one
system for the complaint and then you
allocate or delegate to these / depart
is running on their answers the moma
correct but there's no reason why that
first system doesn't get report from the
second system an entry on there are the
boner link some sort of computerized
link or there's a physical input on to
the first system are you with me to the
make sense so we end up with a book of
pages or book a chapter so we end up
with one software with different
departments of feed in and out but
ultimately there must be one core
responsible RT completed out who starts
with stage two of the money pop doing
well I mean I'll leave that to the expo
so I'm just sorry she saw slight why
this is so this is a great question is
preempted where I was going to go next
when I got the invitation from those
systems that we're talking about these
separate systems because we don't know
how many complaints I mean what metrics
we actually get we just don't know so if
we don't know we don't know how big it
is and we don't know how justifiable it
would then be to have a single complaint
system all I can tell you is I asked
this question professionally it was a
long time ago counselor mrs. Mason will
tell you that I shouldn't speak about a
long time ago but i don't think the
principles change hugely where you know
a merged company of which i was in
charge of complaints for 10 million
customers they were all on different
systems so the first thing I asked was
you know what helped me is this I know
that there's serious ones because I've
got a bunch of people doing that for now
and they're sitting there next to me
answering the serious complaints but
equally I knew there were departments
who have their own complaints which they
dealt with and if you like that power of
their that is in parallel with harrow
formal system but when I found out how
many there were I decided that we did
need a single system reporting system
and actually panda immediately on access
and actually access is an extremely you
know is an extremely powerful tool and
although it didn't fulfill every single
part of the IT directorates wishes it
was something that worked quite well for
five years until they had enough money
to give us something different so I
think that the first question is for how
BIG's the smaller problem because we
know big the major complaint I'll
because those go to the executive of you
seen what we know how big those are the
smaller once the informal ones and we
should be able to capture them what was
really interesting was that the first
thing I captured was the written
complaints departments were receiving
into their individual systems and it was
enough to want to actually understand
control them but then I started asking
questions about how many the call center
god
didn't log because they weren't
formalized and it was something like 50
times higher and when we were talking 50
times higher we were talking about 2,000
times 50 we were talking about a hundred
thousand frames so that is why and I
don't suggest for anything like that but
we're a subset of that issue until you
actually get to the bottom of the of the
tank you can't really tell what you've
got to do to actually an engine look a
mess but that's the answer chairman from
you know that perspective some time ago
of but anyway well anything thinking
I've got one final question when you're
talking to the staff about complaints
when they're going to their induction
process or whatever what's the attitude
towards complaints in some organizations
they're very much welcomed because it's
part feedback for customer performance
in others they sort of forward only
returned and stuck under the carpet what
would you say the cops you at watch it
is why I think I think we were complaint
because we hone in on the world
complaint and it should be customer
feedback because that's important and it
doesn't matter what feedback is and
that's that the way certainly with
customer services when I don't carry out
the inductions myself and that certainly
the customer services and staff is that
you know we have to learn from any
feedback that we get and I think people
do understand that and and if there is
one feedback that's negative and it's
about particular service area they take
it you know very seriously and that's
that's my view and that's what I see and
they want to make sure that doesn't
happen again and nobody likes a
complaint
negative feedback and so that is how we
should be is that we should always
improve and try and improve and as far
as I'm aware and from what per couple of
big star for saying that is how they
look at the complaint and it is if we're
doing something more than we're
continuing to do something wrong if we
if we're not told about it we'll carry
on doing it so we need to have that
feedback to allow us to correct anything
that we are doing wrong otherwise we
don't know we'll continue making the
errors that's my children oh if I Mikey
talk about complaint but there's also
compliment hey we haven't mentioned that
at all but that gets close to throwing
the same you admire of our issues you
were talking about here and i think that
the staff should be complimented I don't
I think we do find John we've got good
song but it doesn't get fed back and I
wear when I was a supervisor and offices
and stuff it was it did a million times
more money but sainted and that was a
good job you did a good i'm really
grateful and supply people's really feel
as though they're like they're valued
but under this comment at all it in here
tonight will bear complying and i think
we should put in perspective this is
about compliments as well exactly and i
can get lost because if you bring up the
lady who hit on customer service and say
oh thanks ever so much so it's really
good does it get fed back yes I mean
they may not go eventually that it's up
to them to think that fact when we do
put those on to our internet internally
this well because the star who need that
yeah that's all I wanted to say okay d
down at the last report we DIF accepting
and we did actually
those out some of those compliments to
show because we are asked to show what
type of compliments were coming in so
they were genuinely real compliments and
you can we do for some of those out to
show them but style far you know if we
if we get the compliment through it does
go directly to that manager or to the
assistant director and and it is packed
down to that member of staff / terminal
if I may I would like to say in their
system some formal process where
individuals who have exceeded is
demonstrated publicly within the council
within the authority so other people
wear that Jane or whatever has done a
good job I think that's fair yeah you
know for baiting paid for that but I
think you can on the back as well let's
bet on record now yeah but have you got
better balance system and if you ever
got a balance system they'll candy was
one large collections might have common
there on that very thing usually we had
a situation with chris tomlin but not so
long ago we're pleased you know come
very by their national awards and I
asked fanatically publicized and I was
told it's not the usual thing to do and
I said well actually just because I've
done that in the past as immense a
climate change in the future and someone
whose works world needs to be priced our
group and that if you now it just came
out in the members bulletin hmm so
sometimes we do need to change them yeah
nothing on the members bolotin is a good
way of exploring that really i think you
have just one little question I probably
going to say something completely
opposite for us it in the pre-meeting
there but I'm i like talking about it
being a customer feedback is there any
reason why you chose not to change the
name of the phone to customer feedback
go ahead rather the key retail
it's compliments of the veins not really
mr. yeah it's this big miners had so
that when somebody sees it on the
internet they wearing brain can look at
it is not just maybe making a complaint
but yeah maybe that's the thought that
we change it to say customer feedback
and we even gather all sorts of feedback
from that thing and not just have it as
a very specific of areas I love young
people okay thanks everybody for a
question and thank you for your honesty
informative answers um I'm not going to
say no comment can't have been that
important and but oh yes and if you
could look at whether or not there's any
way that we can have a sort of quarterly
report as we discussed earlier maybe the
same wanna go to the executive or
different format and think members would
appreciate that and we can then if you
get answer to that question it's
positive or negative you let Paul now
Yves Engler that's not can't just point
out all members get all the accessories
for the science packet so you should you
seeing anybody can usually all no toxic
up to it yet and they're all sent out it
good thank you very much okay
they were down early I didn't chop
nitrogen MobileIron doing to the hot
seat yeah i was seeing the whites of
your eyes house I don't think we detain
you do not frown the most burning issue
i think we had when we looked up ICT in
the number of times in the last year or
sun the final most burning issue was
this question third party support and
whether or not with any opportunity to
reduce the cost of that and i think the
committee would be keen to know whether
you've been able to make any progress on
that front from the party support you
mean on the software etc or software
yeah i mean that's what base it is
before is about it was bit of a tricky
one to do because the world doesn't stay
still if we had not got any additional
services or other stuff since the
resolution was made we haven't made a
saving but since then we have got also
got new things and also about other
agreements through a multi-year that
fished so that has increased the cost of
what i'd like to do with the report was
to break all that down to indicate that
it's not quite like for like but to
actually show what in reality happened
so hopefully it makes sense it makes a
big a row tip so if you only went on
that overall things that stays the same
we major say you have also made a saving
overall because we have actually reduced
the overall budget requirement for this
year by 30,000 and it probably will be
less than that so be more than that by
the end of the year
well because we don't discontinue things
come to new arrangements looked at
software that we don't need to me know
something's still running so the same
you might be seen or next year but we
have done all that and we're continually
doing it basically is what is not a
static process I'm taking another review
of the moment I do that regularly now
and you keep up to date with those of
because we have got other systems one
thing I'm trying to look at take on
boulder coming from the last I to
actually is to see whether we can reduce
the number of systems we've got from
different suppliers to try and
consolidating a bit to get some
economies of scale so make this
protector easier to manage it isn't that
easier because local government fees a
very specialist market there are only
for our customers if you think about it
across the country there aren't that
many suppliers chasing the work because
it is quite niche market and so often
there are there aren't any systems are
cover everything we've got couple of
systems that cover quite a lot of the
council now and we have looked at minor
systems I've got written but a lot of
them are so specialist which is a
specialist piece of software for that
function which mainly used by two or
three people and the council is likely
to them but that's the problem is
consolidating I am now looking around
the market there are no new starters who
are looking to see whether because other
than consolidated systems can be used
they're attacking a ministry things by
that see when they're cost-effective
they're not very expensive now but
should the price come down then that is
near we could go into but we all do
another rhythm am I don't think a lots
going to come out of that because we've
already got so lean in getting rid of
stuff over the last few years but we
should say once we got the new IT
contractor well there might be some
opportunities or podria Rangers has been
to counsel the other way are the
arrangements variety to do things
differently there maybe reduce things
again so we do review it because
obviously we're just in defeat the cost
bounders all of you are unsure so that's
where it is so many Pacific questions
for me Nathan florissant
yeah thank you Andrew in the sperrys of
giving good feedback congratulations on
nine point seven percent it you may
think we'd be sitting here saying well
that's not so good against twenty
percent but you know I think we all knew
we pluck twenty percent out of the air
and I'm I'm pleased that we achieved
almost ten percent and the way you've
stripped it out demonstrates it and it
should therefore be congratulated I'm
hoping that you'd want to say as a
business manager that you were going to
try and get ten percent again it was
basically I'd liked it it was a
difficult process getting there that I
love me it's always the devil price and
we're looking I mean I'm hoping that
there will be some more savings as a
result of the new arrangements we're
going to make hoping to make the IT
coming up in terms of some of the things
that we have for that as part of the
package maybe we remove the need for
some of the more sort of back in
software like virus checking etc mother
to reduce that sort of thing could you
have a lot because the Mulder to realize
the budget for this isn't just for
third-party support the software is also
the third party support of hardware for
some maintenance agreements as our own
bundle of things in there and it will be
the case that we hoping woke them up
make sure that we better discontinue
some of those because they will be
packing things within the arrangements
so it won't need them separately I won't
be inviting twice are you saying the the
transfer of our business systems our
office systems to the cloud the software
to the cloud and therefore within thin
client at this end up in that's why he
do for example far as checking which
computer viruses I have to pay every
year for a virus checking software now
when we move to the cloud the virus
checking of the cloud computing is part
of the package so I've been up anything
I've got to check them is our endpoints
and that's quite simple son the cost
should come down I've been factoring
into the savings I'm try to project for
it and there are other things we have an
email archiving system now when we moved
into play on by archive your emails as
well so there's an almost ninety percent
chance to fund miss something that we're
going me all right I've anymore so once
again Matt an annual cost i can save and
it's looking at things like that to take
them out because it just won't need them
anymore that was a question and it
wasn't actually in the briefing it was
at the bottom of the stairs so I suppose
the bottom of the stairs question is
just as ray Liam chairman if I give you
were there so the urgent question you
ask you don't yes I will do we envisage
that any part or a substantial part what
part of our third-party software will
then resign on the cloud rather than
servers in other places as well as in
our own place right how it d mean the a
model that the option three that went to
cancel the other way which is most
favorite when I think I'd like to pursue
I am pursuing is that we still have
servers but they're dirty ones that live
in the cloud so we don't we will reduce
almost 20 not quite as their Wallace is
there than have a physical kick that we
have to only in terms of service what
we're also looking at is some suppliers
now do the whole package you don't have
a server you buy as a service like
Amazon or ever you just log on to a
system for a web browser they're not
that many of those yet if you looked at
so far the costs don't match the
benefits when we'll come down I mean
really we have already have some system
you see this that you're all familiar
with to look up stuff for committee eath
that kind of system we don't have state
is hosted entirely by people to
providing
and we're just looking to use it and
that was initially slightly more
expensive than there are other offering
but I sayville to work because I didn't
need the service anymore at the
different budget but it swings and
roundabouts because the servers
themselves this for most competitive and
budget but I saved on that budget and
also it takes the well the hassle from
us because they make it work and that's
in an ideal world that's where all my
services would have even forcing the
supplies haven't called out of me yet
I'm hoping they will so I completely
agree that's what I'd like to go ueber
the question just a small question I
think I going on they have custom items
words and I think that nine percent sign
% is very good one of the issues as I
remember it around third-party contracts
was it they're effectively rolling with
the main aisi team contract and there
was a child for mother contract for
those with that then disappear what are
the village as an rpi yeah the charge
that the contract took the main IT
capital contractor thoughts on it is
they support the systems on our servers
in terms upgrading them putting new
patches on removing them when we get rid
of them and just generally liaison with
the third party supplies that is
something I'm still looking at you know
if we can if we do go into a well we're
not using once approached and we decided
at a council we do go that way internet
how we're going to manage that now we
can manage out more efficiently by going
to the systems i just mentioned I've
seen this that doesn't think that way we
don't pay any money
just for that system that was don't do
it and so by moving that model you can
remove that cost for some time he's
moving he's moving the car over there is
a look at it it's not a false economies
that he's moving bubbles ok it's and
that probably eventually you know about
the rpi we must think one of the views
of the eight a previous meeting was the
rpi seemed update to the most
organizations go with CP I know is that
something we try to put in our contract
we've handed look across the board many
of our contracts are now fixed
appearance sometime go up including the
maggot lie negotiate it down that's why
the deal was buggers the downside is you
are locked in normally that's their
trade off others couldn't get any move
under the current contract on the CPR
because they are it is off behind the
contract a few of compromised we've sort
of a half way or I say what marketing
for the extra nothing while on Titan
ever sort of being the middle but
sometimes on a small contract you
moaning learner adds up but you may only
be signing hundred quid so is it really
worth the investment in the time to save
the couple hundred quid because it might
make us more officer time to actually
University when we have to try and
player I only try these bunch of all of
them if I think it's worth pursuing I go
down the line further if I think there's
a substantial say and they're like
adding to the big one I knew there was a
save in there and we when we got hit so
that was a lot that we've got fixed
cable fingers for three years we don't
have any price rising two three years
now but we're locked in for three years
yes I that's the downside to it okay you
know the questions
thank you very much real time thank you
all these answers even though I
understood the current will not be an IT
person I can't make much item seven key
decisions without doing anything in the
KGC is document that we were now run
here folks there are these day in what
happen but I'm not the king of you are
talking to the collection actually
showers
yep and switch down and forcing place to
it I just quickly run through it for you
15 15 response for Essex County Council
consultations that follows open from
previous decision in July when they did
the original consultation and I remember
members looked at him at that point for
information the two sites that are
actually effective is aviation way
industrial estate initially our that's
where they're proposing possibly sign
1615 the trees as it says there to a
great guidance notes the counseling tree
management following on 1715 food safety
and to a great Daniel food safety
service plan the local authorities have
been required to produce and we'll plan
since 2001 and this is the plan that
they're going to put into place
comrades gone a bit and then 1815 health
and safety to agree the annual health
and safety service plan again helped and
safety it's a different that required
local authorities to produce manual
plans in September 2001 thank you 1715
for those of us are on the audit
committee will know that this received
in our risk assessment thought and there
was singled out in particular for
activity and improvement my my only
recommendation for this committee is to
ensure that there's no slippage on the
strawberry because otherwise you know a
risk assessment you know might actually
be worse than it stands currently I
don't know that it is but I have
concerns about it audit has concerns
about it and the whole scheme of risk
assessment your voice yet you know
everything about everything yeah he was
posted well we have two of us are on the
two of them for two more than two of us
are on that all in committee and we can
do of course yeah I wanted like if
anything we need something that is not
something as just procedural this is
again a little absolute we were
concerned because it was some has an
effect on I'm not I've got your district
of the whole with you know it says is
our nighttime economy it was a lot more
economy and we were quite concerned on
that one with the concern throws it to
to lack of manpower back to inspections
being carried out under so many bargains
thank you I think we need to call you in
that's no no I would say to you that
it we were assured as a committee that
there was an action plan on each of
those that weren't good and in
particular the four so therefore it is
the 125 scale that we took knows 115
it's alive 21 whenever there's three
elements to it principally for which
you've got you know I believe it'll be
something like X I'm good and poor or
the equivalent and obviously you know
that gives you a pretty good black on
white physician yeah we had no
excellence you know even though the
goods were you know had that debate and
the pool was standing out filling we
need we need the risk-free much higher
than that and it was acknowledged that
the action plans need to be exhibited to
the Audit Committee so the view doesn't
need to get involved in here unless a
wee committee feel that they're not
achieving really want to go but you've
got a very minor D dennys Murray's
running with this and it's something
that I know that she's going to see
completed quickly as you did she do to
show us you have kept our concerns as it
were did you buy them so that we should
do anything generally I'm sure that
classical Charles would make a beeline
to you saying to be something
okay anything else on the canoe season
document.write paul farley circulating
to work plan at our last meeting give
you those sort of out of the year and
some other topic so we might look at and
speed limits potholes what I what I
would ask I mean we're with a mental /
listen I'm happy to improve we do if you
are if anybody has any really meaning
burning issues they think should be
included then if you could drop an email
to Paul saying what it is and why you
think we should look at it and when I
will have a jacket with an included in
the schedule a large question about
something is carry on the plan that is
of course the portfolio of enforcement
cases which you know I think counselor
black rings its successive for
counselors over the last four years has
drawn to our attention it's been in
excess of 400 500 at some time I I
really would like to know it's on the
work plan I believe I don't have any fun
prints on the road fund which I'd like
to think we need a new assistant
director whose specialism was again
enforcement but are committed to their
bridge with this issue and see some
positive action taken to ensure that you
know we understand what's in Apple
folios enforcement and
commenting man yeah they protecting me
in December with the new assistant
director and they are meeting again in
paper me then she's coming to the first
march meeting me the new enforcement
plan services of the falconer to the
full committee how she's going to deal
with fan enforcement in the future now I
have to start the project i'm very
pleased with her ideas and how she's
gonna shake I'm sure about this brings
cherry hmm so America solar project any
fish on the project a part of that's why
I'm asking he's been a bigger project
icon yeah you can suspend there's a
questioning at earlier on sun or the
project team father Jack those anybody
told me you are now all you need well I
haven't shown any can be at by Rho plus
I'm a u-shape we're prank di vivere
Johnny anyway the point is you know I
want to question God because I now have
relevance okay hi but there's at this a
lot of talk going on about a nice a
thought but when you talk about the
plane I've done if it's relevant to this
committee is that we've got this away
day on Saturday or whenever and and
they're talking about different things
and I think one of things coming up is
to do with litter about this contract
idea of an hour source coming in and
i'll be on I'll show you aware of all
these different things about
now the original asking the person is
just clutches it'll stop you there yeah
yeah if this has just been limited no
it's not love at all go to floaties
sorry Mia no no no that's not it now
you'll see should it be discussed now
well now wasn't it discussed at auction
our was an irrelevance was is if you
have an issue that it would discuss a
lot can you refer that that was going to
ask the question can I refer that to
review committee to none no no not this
days so it's only of the things I've
ever adopted decision yeah okay that's
all it was any other questions of course
anybody we used to make okay your neck I
declare the meeting closed because
you're very basic book 2000 sorry there
was wanting wine on her again so just as
a matter of different realm of the
process we didn't actually a very big
recommendations we propose a committee
never changes made to the customer
feedback on the icing tea alone when it
came to the meeting we sit thank you
very much but we didn't formally razon
goes with the recommendations well
you're quite a recognizable do neither
do we actually agree with the other item
yeah well the other item was at least
left on the basis that we had a series
of questions which we wanted in return
which so to note it and pass it by was
not the case although in the case of the
ICT prospect I think just a note by
agreed that term he'll be looking to
achieve a ten percent yeah yeah sorry
was just come out so we have ten so I'd
like to know the ten percent yes nod
also know the changes made to the
customer feedback process I think it'll
take that you have the reasons it is ok
it because we still were born you still
want numbers on the informal yeah I know
I was being a little more minutes on
that either I don't know whether there's
something you know paul and gerri will
now agree with the one and Cheryl so
write some code she's really sorry don't
worry I don't know a good question you
are not perfectly oh I'd ever and okay
this is nothing else on it clearly she
does okay